bonjour gilbert déjà ni merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
comment expliquez vous cette
recrudescence des cas en belgique
oui bonjour l'explication elle est due
apparemment au regroupement des jeunes
puisque c'est au niveau des plus jeunes
que l'on mesure mais l'augmentation du
nombre des infections
c'est les regroupements qui ont
peut-être été un peu au-delà des
recommandations officielles mais il n'y
a rien d'inquiétant un seul stade les
mesures supplémentaires qui ont été
prises avec le port du masque
obligatoire dès demain est ce que vous
pensez que ce sera suffisant pour
contenir cette compagne à sion oui donc
la peur des autorités c'est de se
retrouver avec une deuxième vague
donc on est loin bien sûr du risque de
de 2k et d'une situation incontrôlée
qu'on a pu on aurait pu la voir il ya
quelques mois est donc là il s'agit
vraiment de prendre les précautions
nécessaires pour éviter absolument une
deuxième bague et donc les mesures ont
été légèrement resserré la phase 5 qui
devait être activée au début août sera
retardée et donc c'est probablement le
1er septembre c'est une phase qui aurait
permis d'ouvrir les foires et les salons
et les regroupements plus important est
donc aujourd'hui avec les mesures qui
ont été prises avec une certaine
obligation un peu plus élargie pour le
port du masque et quelques contrôles en
plus pour les les retours de voyages et
des mesures locales qu'ils soient
renforcés donc ce sont des mesures qui
sont les pouvoirs des d'aidé des
pouvoirs locaux soient un peu renforcé
je pense qu'ils suffiront comme à
empêcher l'arrivée d'une deuxième vague
d'autant plus que comme vous le savez le
personnel soignant est un peu fatigués
de la l'épidémie qui est passé et que
beaucoup de personnes devront également
pris leurs congés pour souffler un peu
en dehors de leur lieu de travail
donc voilà pourquoi les mesures étaient
nécessaires à prendre dès aujourd'hui
et parce qu'on parle quand même d'une
hausse des cas significative qui va
jusqu'à 81 t'est 11% depuis la semaine
dernière avec plus de 200 nouveaux cas
par jour est ce que vous pensez que la
belgique est prête à les préparer à
l'arrivée d'une potentielle seconde
vague on est prêt oui puisqu'on a
actuellement en plus de matériel de
protection plus de tests disponibles
mais donc quand on dit qu'il ya une
augmentation de de plusieurs pourcents
dizaine de pourcents des ça reste un
chiffre relatif
parce qu'on part de chiffres très très
bas donc par exemple pour les admissions
dans les hôpitaux on est passé de 150 à
200 patients ce qui fait quand même 25 %
en plus mais sur un chiffre qui est très
très bas
l'occupation des 10 des soins intensifs
est passé en une semaine de 30 à 40
donc ce sont les pourcentages importants
mais ça reste quand même des chiffres
très très faible d'où il faut prendre
commun avec précaution ces expressions
en cours sans qu'ils sont un peu amené à
choquer donc les décès on est passé de
10 à 15 sur la dernière semaine
donc quand même une augmentation comme
vous dites elle est relative parce que
les chiffres étaient très très bas et
que les mesures qui sont prises c'est
pour éviter
je dirais une recrudescence de
l'épidémie dans un mois ou deux donc
vraiment on agit de façon préventive
très précoce mais il ne faut vraiment
pas s'affoler
à ce stade là la situation dans les
hôpitaux belges au niveau des deux lits
et délibérée animations vous dites que
c'est tout à fait gérable face à
l'augmentation des cas 40 lits sont
occupés actuellement
alors quand même certaines un certain
moment on était au delà de neil donc 40
lits ça reste quand même vraiment un
chiffre très contrôlé alors j'ai vu un
taux des projections épidémiologique
pour la suite des choses tagro en
belgique donc actuellement on a été
jusqu'à 9000 800 morts
si les choses sont bien contrôlés pour
le début de l'automne ou ne devrait pas
être à plus de neuf mille neuf cent
morts dont on est quand même dans un
contrôle qui est beaucoup plus ferme de
la de l'épidémie et bien sûr qu'il ya
plus de tests qui sont fait donc on
dépiste plus de gens et comme vous savez
le chiffre le plus le plus variable
c'est le nombre de patients qui ne sont
pas détectés donc comme je le disais
souvent les chiffres très fiable c'est
les admissions hospitalières et les
admissions soins intensifs et les décès
et la révolution elle et elle elle et
elle est importante mais elle reste tout
à fait contrôlable qu'on parle du
chiffrement très faible en valeur
absolue merci beaucoup gilbert bejjani
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes médecin
anesthésiste président de l'association
belge des syndicats médicaux merci